[Music]
blood verve is podcast
it is production
you're not making no commitment on
camera today
of any shape or form or in the remotest
sense
that there will be some level of
conscientious reigning in
of certain uh styles of engagement
because you might get it wrong i have an
output of 100 you might get it wrong
twice is that basically what you're
saying
if i depends on how wrong i get it like
you know
you know and um i can't tell you i can't
see and tell you that i'm not going to
make mistakes
if i was into a boxing ring i can't tell
you that i'm not going to get here
i prefer the shower one you like this
one
but all i can say is all i can say
is this what i can say is i'll try and
remain as principled as possible
sticking on the islamic principles
taking advice
you will see retractions for me in the
future and if you don't that's a sign of
insecurity
one thing that the medical is they never
like very rarely ever do
you know is retractions and that's one
of my clearest
evidences that they're on the wrong path
um i am going to offer retractions i am
going to make mistakes i am going to
come back
and try and amend them i'm still young
and uh
um have you hit 30 yet 29 yeah
so you know i there's a reason why in
the board starts at 40 by the way
and you know it's interesting because
even aristotle said
that if you want to start being a leader
you should start at 35.
you shouldn't lead the country before
faith and also if interestingly enough
in the american constitution
you can't be a president unless you're
35 years old
you know there's a reason for that but
the point i'm making is that you can't
be
the reason is
you know the quran says when he reached
his prime and he reached four years old
so asking me as a you know not even 30
year old
to do the actions and behaviors of
someone who's 40 and above
i think i will not be able to meet that
promise and especially when mo moses
when he reached his prime we gave him
wisdom and knowledge
and we know i should be 40 years old
so i am not going to be given that if
moses wasn't given at 40 i'm not going
to be giving out 29.
blood brothers podcast for five years